[موسيقى]
تخيل نفسك كده رايح مكان انت مش عارف
الاتجاهات بتاعته ولا حتى معك جي بي اس
او رايح تشوف فيلم والفيلم ده ولا انت
تعرف بتاعه ولا شفت بتاعه ولا تعرف اصلا
ممثلين اللي فيه هتحس بايه
قلقان كنت خايف شويه متوتر طبيعي انت
خايف تبذل مجهود والنتيجه تبقى مش مضمونه
رغم ان الخساره مش كبيره لكن بنحاول ما
نخسرهاش
بتبص على
الزحمه قبل ما تنزل مشوارك
بتتاكد ان الفيلم كويس وبتشوف وكل حاجه
تخيل بقى لو انا بتكلم عليك انت حياتك انت
انت عندك 15 او 17 او 20 سنه
كل يوم بيعدي عليك 24 ساعه بتعمل فيهم
شويه حاجات اليوم بيبقى اسبوع شهر سنين
وبتوصل للاخر لنتايج عناوينها كبيره يا
اما بتبقى راضي عنها يا اما بتبقى مش راضي
عنها وحقيقي انك ممكن تبقى بتعمل حاجات
تاذيك النهارده بس انت ما عندكش الوعي
اللي يفهمك انك بتهدم في نفسك
انا هنا مش بتكلم على السلوكيات اللي في
الحيز الطبيعي الصحي مش بتكلم على
المذاكره اللي انت بتذاكرها عشان عندك
تحمل مسؤوليه مش بتكلم على الرياضه اللي
انت بتلعبها بشكل كويس مش بتكلم على الاكل
المتزن الصحي اللي انت بتاكله انا بتكلم
على حاجات انت ممكن فعلا تبقى مش مدرك
ازاي بتاذيك النهارده التمن سبعميه وستين
ساعه اللي بيعدوا كل سنه لو فضلت تعمل نفس
اللي انت بتعمله كمان عشر سنين هتبقى
موجود فين هل هتبقى شخص ناجح
عنده ثقه واعتزاز بنفسه لانه مش مكسر فيها
لما بيحط هدف بيعرف يوصل له بمثابه يوم
بعد التاني
ولا هتبقى شخص
مكسور مشتت بتلف في دايره مقفوله بالنسبه
لك اليوم هو حاجه
بتستنيها تعدي وبتحرق ساعات عشان تخش تنام
لانه اصلا مش موصلك لحته
انا شخصيا من الناس اللي كانت سهله جدا
تفضل عطلانه في السيناريو الثاني ده شخص
بياذي في نفسه بيهدم في ثقته بنفسه
بيكتسب معتقدات مش صح بيعمل حاجات مش
مناسبه ليه ولكن الحمد لله من حوالي من
تمن لعشر سنين كده خدت يوترن هو اللي
مخليني بفضل الله الشخص اللي انا واقف
النهارده وبتكلم معكم شخص عنده قادر من
الحب مش على طول في ابسط داونز بس علاقتي
بنفسي متوازنه بحبها بحترمها بحاول ما
اعملش اللي ياذي احترامي لنفسي شخص عنده
قدر ادعي قدر من النجاح مهنيا وسريا
طيب تعالوا اعرفكم بنفسي بسرعه واتكلم على
الباك ستوري بتاعتي
انا اسمي محمد حازم شريف انا عندي 33 سنه
انا متجوز من 8 سنين عندي بنوته اسمها
نادين بحبها جدا
كوفاندر وشيف
ابتديتها انا واصدقائي من خمس سنين اسمها
الكوتش وبفضل الله الدنيا ماشيه كويس
وزي ما قلت لكم من حوالي التمن لعشر سنين
ابتديت رحله يعني باودين لها بالفضل رحله
علاج نفسي جميله جدا مريت فيها بمراحل
مختلفه هي اللي فهمتني نفسي فهمتني افكاري
مشاعري فهمتني
اللي انا بعمله ده بعمله ليه وخلتني ابعد
عن حاجات كتير فعلا كانت مسببه لي صراع
وسلوكيات ادمانيه بشكل صريح طيب خلينا
نتكلم سريعه كده الاول في قصتي انا مش
دايما كنت بحب نفسي بصراحه كنت ميال اكتر
ان انا اشوفها قليله كاني معيوب وده معناه
ان انا كنت باصص لنفسي بعدسه مكسوره شويه
فدائما كنت حاسس ان انا انسى خايف خجلان
قلقان من رفض الاخرين ليا
كان نفسي حاجه مش كفايه ان حد يشوفها زي
ما هي
والحقيقه ان المعتقد ده وصل لي بشكل غير
مقصود من الناس اللي حواليا اللي هي كانت
عايزه مصلحتي بس كان عندها فكر معين فعشان
ازوق الراجل ده لقدام هقارنه دايما
بالاخرين هعلق على البقعه اللي على
التيشرت والكلمه اللي اتقالت بشكل مش شيك
في السياق الشيك وعلى الدرجه الناقصه
اعتقادا منهم ان هم كده بيزقوني لقدام وده
مع الوقت بسخ عندي معتقد بيقول انا لا
استحق
تخيل عقلك كانه تربه والافكار اللي بتتزرع
فيه كانها بذره لو البذره دي كويسه
وجودتها كويسه هتطلع حاجه حلوه والعكس
صحيح واحنا صغيرين كلنا بيتزرع في دماغنا
بشكل من خلال تفاعلاتنا مع الاخرين افكار
كتير جدا في جزء من اسمه اللاوعي الافكار
دي هي في منها كويس ومنها الوحش وهي اللي
بتتحكم في الطريقه اللي احنا بنبص بها على
نفسنا وبنبص بها على العالم اللي حوالينا
عايزكم تفتكروا حاجتين صغيرين من اول محطه
اول حاجه ان مشاعرنا دائما بتتلون بلون
افكارنا فلو انا دايما مشاعري غامقه
وكئيبه ده معناه ان انا افكاري دايما
غامقه وكئيبه والعكس صحيح
تاني حاجه ان برضو سلوكياتنا بتتشكل بلون
افكارنا فدائما السلوكيات
المؤذيه بتيجي من افكار مؤذيه ومش صحيه
واحنا لا نليق بيها اقل مننا افكار بتقول
ان انا مش كفايه ان انا مهما عملت الناس
مش هتحبني ومش هتقبلني زي ما انا ان انا
مهما حاولت انا هفشل
تاني شابت في القصه زي ما قلت لكم ان انا
دايما كنت حاسس ان انا مش مبسوط مش مرتاح
مع مشاعري وافكاري بس الفكره ان انا في
الوقت ده ما كنتش اعرف هو المشاعر دي
بيتعمل بها المشاعر الوحشه دي بنعمل بها
ايه واصلا مش فاهم هي بتيجي منين
بس كنت اعرف تلات حاجات بسيطه خالص خالص
ان هي مشاعر وحشه ونام سببه لي الم نفسي
عايز تروح بصراحه
في الفتره دي بالصدفه البحته سن 15 16 سنه
ابتدي تتفرج على
بالنسبه لي في الاول كان حاجه جدا وجديده
جدا حلوه متاحه ببلاش في السر ما حدش يعرف
عني اي حاجه
وفي الوقت ده الموضوع بالنسبه لي كان اشبه
بالمسكن اللي احنا بناخده لما يبقى مقدار
الالم اللي احنا حاسين به عالي وبناخده
مره واثنين وثلاثه كل اما القلم يجي مره
واثنين وثلاثه
انا ما كنتش فاهم ده وقتها بس انا كان في
كابتن وتخدير لالام معينه كان بيكبتها
بشكل قوي هو اللي خلاني اتعلق بيه ومن هنا
عايز اكلمكم على نقطه مهمه جدا
كلنا لما بيكون عندنا مشاعر تقيله وحده
احساس ان احنا ما فيش حد جنبنا ان احنا مش
كفايه كل واحد فينا ممكن يتعامل مع
المشاعر دي بطريقه مختلفه بتتسمى اداه
تكيف او كوبينج ميكانيزم ممكن حد ممكن حد
جايز ممكن حد سوشيال ميديا ممكن شوبينج اي
سلوك من دول لو دخل لحد الافراط وبقينا
متخيلين حياتنا هتقف من غيره ساعتها ممكن
نحط عليه الليبل بتاع السلوك ادماني او
سلوك تعويضي طب يعني ايه ادمان بشكل بسيط
خالص خالص خالص
ببساطه شديده الادمان هو سلوك بيديك احساس
بالمتعه عالي جدا بيكبت او بيسكن مؤقتا
مشاعر معينه
والسلوك ده رغم انه ممكن يبقى اذك جدا
خسايبه كبيره جدا بس انت عندك مشكله كبيره
جدا في انك تتخيل حياتك من غيره
ومهما حصل وبتحاول كتير جدا انك تبطل في
بعض الاحيان وما بتعرفش
الادمان ممكن يبقى اي حاجه
وفي الاغلب الادمان عرض لمشكله مش هو
المشكله زي ما السخونيه والعطس انبكتف او
دليل على وجود فيرس
فالادمان هو دليل على وجود خلل في الافكار
والمشاعر بتاعتك وان انت ما تعلمتش طريقه
تتعامل معهم صح فدورت على ميه مش نضيفه
عشان انت ما عندكش صوص للميه النضيفه
حاجتين
الفتره الاولى كان فيها موضوع بالنسبه لي
كان لذيذ كان شعار المرحله يعني تمام انا
مش عايز اي حاجه تانيه سيبني انت كده
بانتريكشن واكله وانا مش عايز اي حاجه
تانيه في حياتي
الموضوع الاول انا ما كنتش حاسس بعواقبه
مش حاسس بان في اي مشكله وفي الحقيقه كل
مره انا كنت بستهلك كنت بربط نفسي بيه
اكتر بالمشاعر وبالافكار وبالاوقات ومع
الوقت ابتديت اتشد ليه وابتدى استخدامي
يزيد جدا فابتديت اسهر كتير جدا علشان
افضل اتفرج ابتديت اكذب على اهلي علشان
اخبي انا ليه قعدت في البيت رغم ان انا
قلت لهم ان انا نازل وابتديت
احس انه مش كفايه انا عايز حاجه تانيه
الموضوع بالنسبه لي ما بقاش لذيذ وحلو زي
الاول في الفتره دي انا كنت بختبر حاجه
اسمها ديسنسايزيشن
ببساطه شديده لما مخك
يبتدي يلاقي صعوبه في ترجمه الكاميلز اللي
هو بياخدها لنفس مقدار المتعه فتبتدي
دايما بتدور على حاجه اعلى عشان تديك نفس
الشعور ومن هنا الموضوع يبتدي يتفاقم وده
اللي حاسس ان انا بفقد السيطره وده اللي
حسسني ان انا كاني بقيت في سجن ومعيش
المفتاح بتاعه والعلاقه انتقلت من
ايه ده انا مش عايز حاجه تانيه لان انا
عايز اوقف بس مش عارف اوقف ومش عارف اعمل
ايه زي وده بينطبق على كل السلوكيات
الادمانيه في مرحله حلاوه روح لذيذه جدا
في الاول بعد كده الموضوع بيتفاقم لحاجه
مش حلوه خالص وبتخليك تقول انا ايه اللي
راكبني اصلا
حاجتين صغيرين جدا عايزكم دايما تفتكروهم
تكرار اي فعل بانتظام نتيجه ان هو في
مكافاه بيعمل او بيكريت حاجه اسمها هابيت
لوب الهابت لوب هي دايره مقفوله من ثلاث
اضلاع في حاجه اسمها
في حاجه اسمها
ريوورد مخنا مرن جدا اي حاجه تعلمها له
بيتعلمها فلو انا كل شويه وانا محبط وحزين
ومتضايق بتفرج على تيك توك بالساعات او
بعض على السوشيال ميديا او بلعب جيمز وده
بالنسبه لي ممتع فانا باترين ماي برين انا
بقول له بص ده حلو فلما احس تاني بده قل
لي اعمل ده عشان احس بده دائره مقفوله
بدائيه جدا مشتركين فيها مع كل المللز
تاني حاجه
في الاساس في الاساس اي سلوك ادماني بنقع
فيه بيكون عشان نخلي حاجه تروح مؤلمه فلما
ده يبطل يحصل يعني المتعه دي تبطل تكون
موجوده فبطبيعي بندور على حاجه اقوى ودي
من السمات الاساسيه اللي بتيجي بتخليك
تقول انا دلوقتي بعمل سلوك ممكن يبقى
اتكتف
رابع مرحله
ببساطه شديده من 15 الى 23 سنه كانت
المرحله اللي انا بكلمكم عليها ده بتاعها
بتتفرج الموضوع لذيذ تتشد له ابتدى يتفاقم
ابتديت اعاني عايزه اوقف مش عارف يوم بعرف
يومين اخر اسبوع ارجع تاني احس باحباط
واكتئاب الوحشه جدا جدا المرحله الثانيه
بقى اللي هي من 23 سنه لحد النهارده انا
عندي 33 هي بدايه نقطه الصفر في مرحله
التغيير لحد اللقطه اللي انا واقف فيها
النهارده كانت اول نقطه فيها ان انا اصلا
فهمت ان دي مشكله بالصدفه البحث دخلت على
الويب سايت تقول يعني
بتقول شويه تولز والتعامل معاه ففي
المرحله دي انا فعلا ابتديت افهم
وحسيت ان انا معايا سوبر باول انا دلوقتي
فاهم مشكلتي وابتديت اعرف احقق شويه تقدم
ممكن اقعد اسبوعين ثلاثه شهر وقع تاني
قريت كتب كتير في المرحله دي ساعدتني برضو
القرايه مهمه جدا زي مثلا كان في كتاب
اسمه
the في كتب لا تتخيلوها بتتكلم عن المشكله
دي كتابه كتاب قوي جدا بس برضو ده ما كانش
كفايه لان انا كنت لوحدي المرحله التانيه
هي مرحله العلاج الجمعي اللي انا فيها
ربنا رزقني وهو ما يتقالش عليه غير الرزق
ان انا تعرفت على مجتمعاتي علاجيه اونلاين
اوف لاين تعرفت فيها على اصحاب لحد
النهارده احنا مكملين مع بعض ومنها فهمت
نفسي ومنها قدرت اخد كميه ادوات ما كانتش
موجوده عندي في المرحله الاولى اخدت
علاقات فيها امان وقبول واحترام
بقدر اشارك فيها كل اللي عندي واللي قدامي
قابلني ففي مساحه امنه قدرت افهم نفسي
فهمت احتياجاتي النفسيه الطفوليه اللي
موجوده لحد دلوقتي فيا وانا راشد وازاي
اتعامل معاها فعلا كانت مرحله بالنسبه لي
جدا وساعدتني اوصل لمدد امتناع كبيره جدا
المرحله الثالثه والاخيره
اديتها من حوالي اربع خمس سنين دي بقى
مرحله انتقاليه ابتديت افهم فيها في
اللاوعي بتاعي مستوى اعلى بكتير جدا ازاي
الاساءات اللي انا تعرضت لها اثرت جدا في
الطريقه اللي انا شايف بها نفسي وحاجات
تانيه كتير واحده واحده ابتديت اعرف اعمل
فترات اكتر ست شهور وقع سنه واقع اخرهم
المده اللي انا واقف فيها على رجلي حد
النهارده ليه سنتين واربع شهور طيب
اربع دروس بسيطه جدا عايزكم تفتكروهم من
اخر واتمنى يكون الكلام مفيد حتى لو لشخص
واحد هو ده الهدف
اول حاجه نقطه رقم صفر انك تحط ليه
بالمشكله لان انت اصلا لو بتتجنب انك
تسميها مشكله فانت ممكن تضيع حياتك كلها
بتهرب من شويه مراره بسيطه انك تعترف وتقر
ان انا عندي مشكله وممكن توصل لحد شعرك
يشيب وانت لسه محبوس في الحته اللي انت
فيها تاني حاجه
الاعتراف بالمشكله هو الحل بس دي نقطه
البدايه في بعديها بيجي ان انا اقرا ان
انا افهم ان انا اطلب مساعده
او السلوكيات الادمانيه حاجه التعامل معها
لوحدك كانك بتصابع جوريلا وزنها 500 كيلو
تالت حاجه الموضوع محتاج قدر كبير جدا من
الصبر من المحاوله ومن الوقت ما يحاولش
غير الجدع بصراحه اللي يغير افكاره ويقول
انا عندي مشكله وعايز يتغير وعايز اكون
بني ادم احسن لمستقبلي علشان انا مش راضي
باللي انا فيه على اي جانب على جانب
اخلاقي جانب عقائدي على جانب
رابع حاجه ودي بالنسبه لي اكتر حاجه محببه
الى قلبي واللي بتخليني كده قبل ما اطلع
التوكس ببقى متوتر بس بعد كده ببقى مبسوط
ان انا بتكلم
مقدار الحريه واحترام النفس
هاي انك غودت نفسك وبعدت عن حاجه وحققت
فيها تقدم وبتختار بوعي ان دينا سيبني وده
ما يناسبنيش دي حاجه لها طعم ولها زي ما
كنا بنقول في اول توك ده جزء من مفهوم
السعاده الغير ملموس رضا وفلفلمنت اتمنى
هسيبكم في الاخر بحاجه بسيطه خالص اخر
اربع كلمات لاي مشكله ادمانيه ادمتت لازم
يبتدي بيع التراف شخصي تاني حاجه بتفهم
تالت حاجه بتطلب مساعده صعب جدا تعرف تعمل
ده لوحدك ورابع حاجه الموضوع بيتاخد يوم
بيوم بس كده شكرا
[تصفيق]